the reason we didn't participate in any
debates during the 2020 race was because
the campaign decided not to um obviously
we couldn't participate in the
republican and democrat the the
commission on presidential debates
debate because that was that's a cartel
and they keep everyone else out but
there were opportunities to participate
in debates with other third party
candidates and the campaign decided not
to
now i don't know why that was they said
it was because well we don't want to be
seen as being at the kids table
one percent two percent three percent
half a percent we're at the kids table
and we need to
take our position that we're at now
stand on the kids table and try to use
it as leverage to get up higher that was
a sort of microcosm of many problems in
the campaign we ran a really good
campaign for someone a candidate who was
already comfortably ahead by a couple of
points and uh you know didn't want to
rock the boat too much but if you're
trying to be a disruptive candidate
who's presenting a stark contrast to the
other two parties that wasn't being done